[Musique]
parlons d'europe avec la maison de
l'europe des yvelines sur sensations
avec le soutien financier de l'union
européenne
on saura tout et à tous bienvenue dans
parlons d'europe une émission qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la conférence
sur l'avenir de l'europe et de la grande
consultation citoyenne qui est
actuellement en cours vous êtes
d'ailleurs invité à donner votre avis et
partager vos idées sur la plateforme
numérique futur e u point europa.eu
thème de ce numéro les institutions
européennes on a parfois du mal à s'y
retrouver comme a pu le constater maiolo
bas qui est allé vous posez la question
je sais qu'il ya le parlement et à la
commission européenne et qui a le
conseil des ministres européens
non non franchement à strasbourg et à
bruxelles oui voilà
le parlement européen non non non tu
rates un malade vous pourriez pas vous
citer
non pour beaucoup le rôle et le
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes est parfois floue on vient
de le voir mais pas d'inquiétude notre
journaliste nicolas kirillovitch est
avec nous pour nous éclairer sur le
sujet bonsoir nicolas bonsoir matisse
effectivement je vais essayer de vous
aider il ya cette institution européenne
la première peut-être la plus importante
politiquement c'est le conseil européen
il réunit les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'union européenne
27 pays aujourd'hui depuis le départ de
la grande-bretagne et de et le break
site le conseil européen le conseil
aussi on l'appelle parfois il fixe les
grandes orientations politiques de
l'union européenne aujourd'hui il est
présidé par l'ancien premier ministre
belge charles michel en résumé le
conseil européen celle ainsi c'est
l'instance suprême qui se concentre sur
les grandes orientations politiques et
générale de l'union européenne un peu
comme si vous aviez en réalité 27
emmanuel macron qui se réunissait pour
décider de l'impulsion à donner aux
politiques européennes et qui tranche
aussi en cas de blocage persistant entre
les institutions à côté de ce conseil
européen il ya la commission européenne
ll est gardienne des traités de l'union
européenne elle défend les intérêts de
l'union européenne parfois au conseil
européen ce sont un peu les égoïsmes
nationaux qui joue là avec la commission
européenne ce sont vraiment les intérêts
de l'union européenne qui sont défendues
la commission européenne et est la seule
à être doté de l'initiative législative
dans le domaine des compétences de l'ue
eux contrairement à la france par
exemple où les parlementaires peuvent
faire des propositions de loi là c'est
seulement la compétence de la commission
open aujourd'hui présidée par
l'allemande ours ou la vendline et il y
à 27 membres qui 27 membres de cette
commission européenne un pour chacun des
pays aux gros pays elle les grosses
commissions généralement ça marche ainsi
le front c'est thierry breton est en
charge du marché intérieur c'est lui qui
était responsable des législations sur
le numérique qui doivent permettre à
l'europe d'être un peu plus indépendant
sur le sujet vis-à-vis des géants du
numérique américains et chinois alors
vous vous en avez cité deux médias aussi
je prends le conseil de l'union
européenne nicolas tout à fait le
conseil de l'union européenne à ne pas à
ne pas confondre avec le conseil
européen dont j'ai parlé aux début le
conseil de l'union européenne où il
réunit les ministres de chacun des états
membres pour voter les lois proposées
par la commission européenne j'espère
que vous suivez pour l'instant
difficiles c'est difficile compliqué
donc le conseil de l'union européenne
écho législateur avec le parlement
européen le conseil de l'union
européenne ce revenu selon les
compétences de chacun des ministres s'il
ya un sujet des transports ça va être
les 27 ministres des transports des pays
membres de l'ue eux qui vont se réunir
pour amender peut-être ou modifier les
propositions de loi de la commission
européenne et je vous le disais il fait
cela en parallèle avec le parlement
européen que l'on connaît un peu mieux
ils sont 705 c'est parlementaires
européens qui eux agissent donc en co
législateur avec le conseil de l'union
européenne on peut citer les autres
trois grands d'autres institutions de
l'union européenne il ya la cour de
justice de l'union européenne qui est
chargée d'examiner la légalité des actes
européen là c'est un peu plus complexe
mais il y à cette cour de justice de
l'union européenne il y aussi la banque
centrale européenne présidée par
christine lagarde qui elle est en charge
de gérer la monnaie unique des 19
membres de la zone euro et puis il ya la
cour des comptes européenne qui marche
comme la cour des comptes en france voir
si beaucoup nous allons vers le haut par
matisse je pense que j'y vois un peu
plus clair en tout cas merci beaucoup
pour ces précisions parlons d'europe
avec la maison de l'europe des yvelines
sur sensations avec le soutien financier
de l'union européenne
et on va revenir en france à présent
pour s'intéresser aux relations
entretenues par notre parlement et plus
particulièrement le sénat avec les
institutions européennes et nos voisins
européens
corentin alonso est avec le sénateur
jean françois rapin président de la
commission des affaires européennes vous
êtes sénateur du pas de calais vous êtes
le président de la commission des
affaires européennes du sénat il y en a
aussi
une haute commission aux affaires
européennes à l'assemblée nationale
présidée par la députée sabine tilaï
quel est le rôle de ces deux commissions
la d'abord ces deux commissions elles
sont définies et elles existent parce
que la constitution l'a décidé donc
elles ont aujourd'hui un rôle à la fois
d'information auprès des différentes
chambres dans lesquelles elles sont
aussi bien le sénat que l'assemblée
nationale auprès des collègues sur
l'actualité sur l'information européenne
et notamment sur les textes qui sortent
elle a aussi un rôle de contrôle là un
rôle de contrôle des textes au travers
ce qu'on appelle la subsidiarité la
proportionnalité puisque l elle précise
finalement aussi les textes européens
sont tout à fait conformes au plan de la
subsidiarité et de la proportionnalité
avec ce qu'attendent les états les états
membres et comment ils le reçoivent ça
c'est le premier point puis on a aussi
un rôle et de
d'interpellation auprès de nos
gouvernements pour que le gouvernement
qui a son propre mandat et son propre
calendrier puisse aussi avoir de
l'information de la part des parlements
nationaux et entre autres chez nous du
sénat sous la forme et on présente ça
sous la forme de résolution de
résolution qui
qui incite le gouvernement à porter le
message du parlement qui en dernier lieu
vis-à-vis directement des institutions
européennes nous pouvons émettre des
avis politique sur certains textes sur
certaines directives
sur certains règlements et nous et nous
ainsi nous pouvons nous pouvons influer
et le sénat fait partie ces institutions
qui arrive à influer un petit peu sur
les institutions européennes au travers
ses différentes ces différents outils
alors à vous le savez nous avons pleine
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne qu'est ce que vous en
attendez est-ce que c'est l'occasion de
parler plus d'europe au sénat mme six
nominations je ne sais pas si ce sera
l'occasion de parler plus d'europe en
tout cas c'est une charge de travail
complémentaire pour les deux chambres
parlementaires puisque nous animons bien
lors des réunions qui sont propres et
aux institutions telles qu'elles sont
établies entre autres je pense à la
cosaque qui est la conférence des
organes chargés justement que ces
affaires de ces affaires européennes et
donc nous sommes réunis sous deux
formats avec des membres de chaque
commission des parlements nationaux
qui travaillent sur les sujets sur les
sujets européens et donc nous la
présidence cette année puisque c'est
l'année de la présidence française donc
à la fois savent-ils et moi-même
coprésidents 7,7 kozak après il ya des
événements parlementaires qui sont qui
sont proposés alors bien sûr on a reçu
nous la cosac des présidents les
présidents des des chambres
parlementaires des vingt-sept sont venus
à paris et en visio et et nous essayons
eux dès lors de deux constituées de
réunir tout le monde mais sous
l'autorité de la france
voilà donc c'est une charge de travail
complémentaire administrative
diplomatique mais c'est aussi un beau
challenge est ce que les médias et les
politiques mais triste il suffisamment
les sujets européens c'est très
difficile c'est très difficile j'ai fait
j'ai fait récemment j'ai organisé
récemment au sénat une table ronde
justement pour eux à la fois échangé
avec les médias nationaux mais aussi les
médias européens sur la façon dont nos
patrouilles ont mieux les uns et les
autres communiquer c'est sûrement de
notre faute les sujets européens
paraissent très éloignés de nos citoyens
est forcément ci s'était éloignée des
citoyens ça intéresse beaucoup moins la
presse néanmoins il ya des choses quand
même essentiel très importante
je rappelle que
l'europe a des conseillers des
compétences quasi exclusive sur le sur
l'agriculture sur la pêche
endroit transfrontalier on a des sujets
qui sont des sujets de migration
aujourd'hui et avec un avec un rôle très
important de plus en plus important qui
doit être jouée par l'europe donc tous
ces sujets doivent devrait intéresser
par est intéressé plus peut-être qu'on
en parle aussi nous on n'a pas su à un
certain moment
vulgariser le message européen quand je
dis vulgariser ce n'est pas péjoratif
c'est comment porter le message européen
à la portée de tous nos concitoyens
comment rapprocher l'europe des citoyens
comment faire ce concept que je défende
ans dans beaucoup de mes allocution le
gong le contexte d'europe à la maison
justement quelles sont les pistes pour
essayer d'améliorer ce ce sujet puisque
c'est quand même qu'il ya quelque chose
d'important pour la démocratie
dans les deux sens c'est à dire que les
politiques doivent faire beaucoup de
pédagogie l'europe c'est de la politique
l'europe c'est de la diplomatie mais
l'europe c'est aussi de la pédagogie
c'est beaucoup de pédagogie de notre
part les élus et puis les médias ont
peut être aussi une réflexion sur la
façon dont ils doivent présenter les
sujets les sujets européens et les
rendre beaucoup plus à la fois plus
concret
mais plus accessible merci beaucoup je
la france à rabat parlons d'europe avec
la maison de l'europe des yvelines sur
sensations avec le soutien financier de
l'union européenne
une émission qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe et de la grande consultation
citoyenne qui est actuellement en cours
vous êtes d'ailleurs invité à donner
votre avis et à partager vos idées sur
la plateforme numérique futur e au point
europa.eu et dans ce nouveau numéro nous
allons parler des politiques européennes
de mobilité partir étudier à l'étranger
est ce une chance pour ceux qui ont pu
ou voudraient en bénéficier michael
aubin est allé à votre rencontre pour le
savoir c'est une des rares choses qui a
un coût raisonnable je pense
et qui est utile alors ça sert à ça
permet cette mode étudiants de pouvoir
travailler à l'étranger de faire autre
chose dans de changer de culture voir
quelque chose de différent du coup c'est
plutôt pour les étudiants étrangers
enfin français ou étrangers qu'ils
veulent partir dans d'autres pays
européens
je sais que c'est pour les étudiants
pourrait effectivement faire des
études à l'étranger et corentin alonso
nous a rejoint bonsoir corentin montfort
matisse vous avez justement nous parler
du programme erasmus plus qui fête ses
35 ans cette année or tout le monde a
déjà entendu le mot erasmus mais d'où
vient-il alors il vient du philosophe
néerlandais du 16e siècle erasme qui a
voyagé en europe pour s'enrichir et
développer son humanisme par ce
personnage incarne bien l'objectif du
programme d'action européen pour la
mobilité des étudiants et quand ce
programme erasmus a été lancée justement
alors il a été adopté en 1987 mais il
vient de fêter ses 35 ans d'ailleurs
mais il n'aurait pas vu le jour sans
sofia corradi une professeure italienne
dont le surnom est mama erasmus en 1958
elle est diplômée de l'université
columbia aux états unis mais en revenant
à rome son université italienne ne
reconnaît pas son diplôme elle doit donc
étudier une année supplémentaire elle
décide alors de se battre pour la
reconnaissance des diplômes obtenus à
l'étranger il faudra attendre donc 1987
pour que le programme soit adoptée sous
la commission du français jacques delors
alors à sa création le programme compte
onze pays qui participaient l'allemagne
la belgique le danemark l'espagne la
france la grèce l'irlande l'italie les
pays bas le portugal et enfin le royaume
uni alors aujourd'hui il y a trente
trois pays qui participent à ce
programme mais le royaume uni n'en fait
plus partie depuis le 1er janvier 2021
conséquence vous le savez du bric site
depuis 2014 le programme s'appelle
d'ailleurs erasmus plus les étudiants
mais aussi les collégiens les lycéens
les demandeurs d'emploi peuvent partir
en stage et à l'étranger en bénéficiant
d'une bourse doté d'un budget de 14 6
milliards d'euros pour la période allant
de 2014 à 2020 il a vu son budget
augmenter encore davantage de plus de
80% en passant à 26 milliards d'euros là
tout récemment pour la période 2021 2027
or 10 millions d'européens devraient
pouvoir en bénéficier au cours de cette
période les français sont ceux qui
partent le plus avec 57 mille voyages
réalisés en sur l'année 2019 avant la
pandémie le pays privilégié des français
c'est l'espagne et après un voyage
erasmus 83 % des étudiants se disent se
sentir plus européen l'objectif est donc
acquis pas ça donne envie de partir
merci beaucoup corentin pour ces
précisions parlons d'europe avec la
maison de l'europe des yvelines sur
sensations avec le soutien financier de
l'union européenne
et il n'ya pas qui rase plus plus
d'ailleurs d'autres programmes de
mobilité existe béatrice angrand et la
présidente de l'agencé service civique
focus tout de suite sur le corps
européen de solidarité elle est
interrogée par hugo casadamont alors le
corps européen de solidarité c'est géré
par la commission européenne
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
tout d'abord ses principales actions le
corps européenne solidarité c'est
d'abord un programme qui est financé par
la commission européenne mais qui est
gérée par des agences nationales
européennes en france c'est l' agence du
service civique qui déploie le corps
européenne solidarité c'est un programme
en fait de volontariat qui a deux volets
qui permet donc à des jeunes de faire un
volontariat en europe de deux à douze
mois donc on peut aussi commencer par
une mobilité courte ce qui convient à
certains types de public deux à douze
mois pour faire ce programme on reçoit
une aide au transport une aide au
logement est l'équivalent de l'argent de
poche qui est dont le niveau est adapté
en fonction du niveau de vie du pays
dans lequel on va et puis le deuxième
volet du programme
quand européen de solidarité c'est ce
qu'on appelle des projets de jeunesse de
participation des jeunes qui permet en
fait à des jeunes à des groupes de
jeunes informel d'accéder à des
financements pour développer un projet
de solidarité et je crois que c'est à
peu près les seuls financements
existants conclus qui peuvent être
octroyées à des groupes de jeunes
informel donc c'est une très belle
action aussi alors en quoi c'est
important justement ce corps européen de
solidarité est ce que ça permet
peut-être de renforcer le sentiment
d'appartenance européenne auprès des
jeunes l'idée du camp européenne
solidarité c'est d'utiliser
la solidarité l'intérêt général la
générosité comme truchement comme levier
pour rassembler les jeunes européens
effectivement pour qu'ils exercent ce
sentiment d'appartenance donc moi j'aime
bien cette idée d'agir collectivement
pour pour se rencontrer la rencontre
c'est un beau mot
et je crois que c'est c'est vraiment ça
cette idée de construire l'europe
ensemble par des actions des actions
citoyennes comme l'aide aux migrants
lutter contre le plastique dans les
océans
et des des jeunes enfants à faire leurs
devoirs enfin toutes les actions rendre
visite à des personnes âgées isolées
dans d'action qu'on peut faire dans le
corps européen de solidarité dans un
autre pays alors maintenant qu'on sait
quelles actions on peut faire comment
est-ce qu'on peut donner envie aux
jeunes justement de de faire ses actions
alors d'abord avant de donner envie il
faut déjà informé et ça s'est il faut
toujours remettre l'ouvragé sur le
métier sur l'information pour ce qui est
de donner envie à vraiment un moyen qui
fonctionne bien c'est de s'appuyer sur
les paires le peer to peer comme on dit
en anglais d'utiliser afin de solliciter
des jeunes qui ont déjà vécu cette
mobilité européenne
pour les le failli leur demander d'aller
au delà valoriser d'en faire la
promotion auprès de jeunes tout ce qui
passe en fait par les role models ça
fonctionne très bien utiliser aussi
évidemment les canaux utilisés par la
jeune génération comme comme les réseaux
sociaux il faut reconnaître que ça
marche assez bien parce que on a
beaucoup de demandes pour le corps
européen de solidarité qui a une très
bonne réputation
merci beaucoup merci à vous parlons
d'europe
la mobilité des jeunes est importante
mais en quoi ça leur est bénéfique en
quoi est ce une source d'enrichissement
mais surtout comment une mobilité peut
être s'inscrire dans le parcours
scolaire ou professionnelle corentin
alonso en parle avec michel moquin
déléguée adjointe académique aux
relations européennes internationales et
à la coopération de versailles madame
mais quand vous êtes chargé de mettre en
oeuvre la stratégie d'ouverture
européenne et internationale pour
l'académie de versailles alors justement
quelle est cette stratégie
alors oui bien sûr en fait notre service
est un service du rectorat un petit
service et nous mettons en oeuvre et
nous élaborons la stratégie académique
d'ouverture open international
qui est piloté par la rectrice de
l'académie versailles en avec bien sûr
en
nous faisons aussi attention aux
priorités nationales et aux spécificités
territoriales donc nous nous y
travaillons sont quatre axes
prioritaires donc l'offre scolaire
internationale
deuxième axe tout ce qui est
coopération bilatérale troisième axe la
mobilité pour tous et la formation des
personnels en quatrième axe quels sont
les partenaires que vous mettez en place
on a des partenariats institutionnels et
des partenariats
européens bien sûr donc institutionnel
on a des partenariats avec france
éducation internationale qui met en
place des programmes pour les assistants
de langues notamment qui met en place
aussi des séjours professionnels et des
séjours linguistiques pour les
enseignants qui veulent partir
se former en europe et une avec
également l'agencé rasmusson plus de
bordeaux et puis nous avons des accords
de coopération avec des autorités
éducatives de différentes régions
notamment la région de madrid où la
région
le land plutôt de nord
nord westphalie et puis également le
district de etienne en chine et les
cégeps de l'ess au canada alors
justement vous avez parlé du programme
erasmus plus pour la période 2021 et
2027 le budget a augmenté de près de 80%
l'objectif c'est de le faire voyager
plus de 10 millions d'européens au cours
de ces six années vous votre travail
c'est d'encourager justement à ces
mobilités
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce que ça te permet
comment à quel niveau c'est enrichissant
justement de partir à l'étranger
déjà il faut savoir qu'on forme les
enseignants on apporte de l'information
aussi dans les établissements pour que
eux mêmes soient acteurs et puissent
candidater à des accréditations erasmus
plus pour les élèves des établissements
notre public cible nous à la dareic ce
sont les enseignants les personnels
d'encadrement les personnels
administratifs et on a nous mêmes
mis en place deux accréditations une sur
le secteur scolaire et une sur la voie
professionnelle pour sur ces six années
qui nous restent sur ce programme 21-27
pouvoir envoyer environ 2500
personnel en formation donc en europe
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce quelle est la
valeur ajoutée c'est ça que vous me
poser comme question la valeur ajoutée
c'est de pouvoir ouvrir un établissement
à l'europe et à l'international
permettre à des jeunes de partir en
mobilité de s'enrichir ailleurs que leur
parcours soit reconnu dans inscrire su
scolaire c'est à dire partir en mobilité
ça ne doit pas être finalement ensuite
un handicap quand on revient et qu'on
est tout à recommencer donc que cette
mobilité elles sont vraiment inscrits
dans le parcours scolaire de l'élève
alors quand on pense aux mobilités on
pense souvent aux études supérieures
mais pour les élèves décrocheurs est ce
qu'il existe aussi des solutions alors
il n'y a pas que les élèves décrocheurs
on peut partir en mobilité haut dès la
classe de 4e vous avez des programmes
franco-allemand qui vous permettent de
partir étudier pendant trois mois ou six
mois ce sont le programme brigitte
sauzay voltaire qui vous qui permettent
un qui permet à un élève de partir dans
un établissement
suivre un cursus scolaire et quand il
revient sa mobilité elle est totalement
partie intégrante de ce cadeau de sa
scolarité il n'ya on pense bien sûr aux
étudiants des universités mais aussi les
lycées professionnels qui met en place
la mobilité depuis de très longues
années et donc c'est intégrer aussi dans
des parcours de formation en entreprise
ils partent pour quatre à huit semaines
en entreprise et quand ils reviennent
évidemment ils sont voilà ils sont
riches y d'une expérience
professionnelle culturelle linguistique
qui est
très important ces dernières années des
doubles diplômes on se sont développées
je pense
bachibac avec le bac espagnol abibac
avec le bac allemand les classes
européennes aussi âmes est-ce que ça
c'est une dynamique que vous souhaitez
amplifié ces classes qui sont déjà sur
le savoir que c'est double bac nous en
avons déjà 16 dans notre académie
khademi de versailles ce qui est déjà
pas mal
alors on peut faire mieux bien sûr mais
faut savoir qu'il ya aussi une politique
nationale on peut pas ouvrir des
bachibac des abaques est partout donc
c'est en fonction aussi
du territoire parce que il faut que les
élèves aient envie de s'inscrire dans
vos bois rue d'ostwald il faut pouvoir
recruter des professeurs il faut qu
ensuite il ya une continuité pédagogique
vers ensuite des sections notamment
section européenne ou sections
internationales merci beaucoup michel
vaut un prix parlons d'europe
et les politiques de mobilité évolué de
nouvelles mesures se mettent en place
pour favoriser les études ou les
formations à l'étranger marie terre
vedrenne eurodéputé est a vécu vos
casadamont alors marie pierre védrine
vous êtes eurodéputés mais vous avez est
également directrice de la maison de
l'europe de rennes de 2016 à 2019
maintenant que vous êtes au parlement
européen est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer en quoi c'est important de
porter au niveau européen la notion de
mobilité la notion de mobilité des
jeunes se sentant de différentes façons
ça peut être une mobilité rien que 10 km
parfois qui peut être un obstacle pour
des jeunes au parlement européen
forcément notre enjeu c'est de favoriser
la mobilité aussi européenne qu'elle
soit source d'opportunités bien sûr en
matière d'employabilité parce que quand
on va dans un autre pays on apprend
d'autres langues on a apprend d'autres
compétences mais plus largement c'est un
projet aussi d'ouverture c'est un projet
commun où on va aller rencontrer
d'autres cultures plus largement et
d'autres citoyens donc c'est ça notre
enjeu c'est au travers de ce programme
erasmus qui est une des plus belles
réussites de l'union européenne va
donner cette envie de découvrir de
s'ouvrir et de développer des
compétences qui feront que ben comme je
le disais plus tard ben vous aurez aussi
ses critères de prise de risque aux yeux
des employeurs qui favoriseront votre
place dans le marché du travail vous
parlez des jeunes le programme erasmus
c'est pas que pour les jeunes justement
on a tendance à l'oublier comment est ce
que on peut peut-être parler plus de 7
de cet aspect là peut-être plus dans les
médias les réseaux sociaux comment
toucher d'autres publics effectivement
la mobilité elle touche les plus petits
dès l'école primaire jusqu'aux plus
âgées notamment ça peut toucher les
enseignants aussi ça peut toucher les
élus ça peut toucher les entrepreneurs
donc c'est extrêmement important de
justement démocratiser le pro le
programme faire en sorte qu'il soit
accessible à tous donc il ya lever les
barrières des barrières des fois qu'on
peut soi-même se mettre en disant ben je
ne vais pas aller dans un pays parce que
je ne parle pas telle ou telle langue
alors que l'objectif justement c'est de
développer ses compétences donc notre
enjeu c'est de
augmenter l'enveloppé budgétaire pour
toucher de plus en plus de monde et puis
faire sauter ces différentes barrières
c'est vrai que vous avez raison la
communication joue aussi un rôle
extrêmement important donc ça passe par
des plateformes aussi peut-être qu'ils
sont plus accessibles ou qui répertorie
justement toutes ces opportunités
la mise en place de réseaux européens il
ya beaucoup de choses qui se
progressivement compte continue de se
développer pour favoriser cette mobilité
c'est quelque chose dont on parle
beaucoup en français ce qui est ces deux
on en parle de façon égale dans toute
l'europe parce qu'il ya autant de
français qui partent faire de mobilité
que d'espagnols ou peut-être que deux
roumains par exemple c est vrai que
quand on regarde les statistiques
d'utilisation en quelque sorte de ce
programme on voit des différences entre
les différents états on voit même à
l'intérieur des états différentes
différence quand on vient de zones
métropolitaines quand on est à
l'université et c'est donc notre enjeu
justement c'est bien de faire en sorte
que ces opportunités elles soient
accessibles à tous donc la question de
la connaissance de ces accès de ces
mobilités et puis la question de
l'accessibilité donc c'est un travail
global et notre enjeu c'est de mettre
justement tous ces acteurs aussi
européens à la même table pour favoriser
là justement le fait que tout le monde
possible en bénéficier et si vous aviez
quelqu'un l'a maintenant en face de vous
qui hésitent à faire une mobilité
qu'est ce que vous lui diriez pour lui
donner envie à fons d'abord ne tenait
pas ne te mets pas de barrière ne te
mets pas de limite tu vas vivre une
magnifique expérience expérience de vie
il il faut se lancer que chacun trouve
sa propre aux mobilités aussi une
mobilité de 15 jours pour certains c'est
déjà extrêmement
challenge ans alors que pour d'autres
partir pendant six mois non ça paraît
naturel donc que chacun va trouver aussi
sa mobilité une fois qu'on ya goûté on
n'a plus envie d'arrêter merci marie
pierre védrine merci à vous et puis vous
le savez une grande consultation
citoyenne est actuellement en cours vous
êtes invités à vous exprimer et à
imaginer l'europe de demain je vous
rappelle d'ailleurs l'adresse de la
plateforme numérique future rue fois
europa.eu plateformes mises en place à
l'occasion de la conférence sur l'avenir
de l'europe vous pourrez ainsi partager
vos idées sur différents thèmes
changement climatique qu'ils sont et
justice sociale emploi démocraties
européennes transformation numérique et
bien d'autres parlons d'europe s'est
terminée merci d'avouer à vous d'avoir
été avec nous on se retrouve très
bientôt cette émission a été enregistrée
en marge du 20e anniversaire de la
maison de l'europe des civils on espère
avoir répondu aux principales questions
que vous vous posiez et n'hésitez pas à
prolonger le débat sur nos réseaux
sociaux
c'était parlant d'europe sur sensations
plus d'infos sur maison europe 78e
[Musique]